it can seem very confusing why certain
long-term relationships survive and some
don't
it can from afar
look as if it's the most cruel and
alarming sort of lottery
trying to explain love to a child or a
visitor from another planet promises to
be a perplexing matter indeed
all couples on their wedding day are
united in wanting to make things work
then for reasons beyond anyone's
comprehension
some of them simply seem to dissolve and
others don't
to remove some of the terrifying element
of apparent chance and encourage us to
work on the right aspects of our own
couples
it may be helpful to become deliberately
reductive about the real reasons why
breakups occur
we need in this regard first to discount
certain causes that gain far too much
air time relative to their actual
likelihoods
of course sometimes people break up
because one party wants a younger
partner or because they want better sex
or because they are seeking a more
exciting companion
or because their hobbies or political
views have drifted apart
or because things have somehow grown
stale
but let's quickly try to reduce the role
we give to such explanatory factors
given the costs of breakups given the
massive investments that people make in
being together
given the chaos generated if there are
children
one can assert with a high degree of
confidence that almost no one ever
splits up for such familiar reasons
the real reason lies elsewhere
the real reason for breakup lies in one
or both spouses sense that they have not
been heard
that something very important to them
has been disregarded
that their point of view has not at a
fundamental level been acknowledged and
honored
it doesn't matter what the subject of
this non-hearing happens to be
it could be that they haven't been heard
about their views on money or on the way
the children are being brought up or on
how their weekends should be managed or
on how intimacy occurs or doesn't occur
it's feeling unheard for our differences
that is unbearable
it's never the presence of differences
per se
we don't break up because a partner
doesn't agree with us
we could stand not getting what we want
we could stand a partner who votes
another way than we do or who is no
longer as young as they once were or who
has annoying friends or different tastes
in holidays
what we can't stand is someone who
blocks us when we try to articulate how
troublesome we find these areas of
divergence
when our unique way of looking at
existence
seems a matter of basic indifference
that is too lonely and enraging to bear
it's better to be single than unseen
after all the unseen are alone anyway
whatever their ostensible relationship
status
there is a big difference between a
partner not doing what we want and a
partner not hearing what we want
it's entirely possible that one would
remain with someone who doesn't share
most of our interests
so long as they happen to accept and
signal an understanding of how much
these interests matter to us
it would be possible for us to live with
someone who doesn't want the same sort
of sex as we do or wants no sex at all
so long as they can at points see
matters from our position
and can give a modicum of empathy to our
hopes and longings
we could be with someone whose needs for
affection run in a different direction
so long as they have the courage to
listen to how ours operate
we don't need partners to agree with us
on everything
we need them to give off signs that they
can accept the scale and legitimacy of
our vision
i understand is the phrase that could
single-handedly rescue more long-term
relationships than any number of
anniversary celebrations or therapy
sessions
it deserves to be known as the most
romantic phrase in existence
there is a lot of hope in this thesis
if we want to stay together we don't
need to be exceptionally beautiful or
rich
we don't need to rely on chance
we don't need to have brilliant sex or
friction-free alignments of interests
we just need to make sure that we are
people who listen
who when the partner has something very
important they need to get across to us
can bear to take things on board
can bear to acknowledge an opposite
position can bear to say
i can see this matters a lot to you
and i will try my hardest to think about
it and see what i can do about it
from here it really doesn't matter if
things radically change or not
the vital work will have been done
and the relationship will have been
assured
people described as defensive may have a
thousand charms
but we should know that the most flawed
open person is preferable to the most
seemingly accomplished defensive one
the person we should settle down with
isn't the most attractive or the
cleverest it's the one who feels no
pride or compunction in readily saying
i can hear what you are saying and how
much this matters a lot to you
i get it
or because i love you this makes me
curious
tell me more
this person will surely one day annoy or
frustrate us mightily
everyone does
will just be highly unlikely ever to
want to break up with them
connect is a card game to foster
connection and closeness with 100
questions that help couples to rekindle
affection
click the link on screen now to find out
more